the first person to ever be photographed  didn't know they were in 1838 while  Louis De Guerre took this famous  exposure they were getting a shoe shine  we don't know anything about this person  we know that they were born a long time  ago but do we know who the earliest born  person ever photographed is well there's  kind of two answers this is Caesar an  American slave photographed in 1851 a  slip of paper mounted on the back of the  frame says he was born in  1737. that would make him 114 years old  at the time this photo was taken but so  far no one has been able to confirm the  year of his birth the earliest born  person ever photographed whose age has  been verified is John Adams a Shoemaker  from New England born in 1745 this guy  was 11 years old when Mozart was born